foreign
[Music]
Ottawa Ottawa I'm there September 21st
uh Pittsburgh October 19th Cleveland
October 20th Detroit Michigan Orlando
Florida Fort Myers Richmond Virginia
Baltimore Maryland Philadelphia and
reading uh can't wait to get out there
the only um the other ones are pretty so
are sold out so that's what I'm only
saying the ones that aren't uh I think
there actually are some tickets left for
Edmonton
I don't know uh but yeah I go to
chrisley.com to get them tickets
um and that's really what's going on
here dude uh we got that merch we got
that merch going on and we love the
merch of course we do it's got the
pockets stay deep we've got the pockets
stay deep exclusive merch and we say
exclusive just because it's not
exclusive at all but that's what makes
it absolutely amazing it's uh you could
say it's exclusive means pretty much
nothing who decides the uh who decides
the number of exclusive of exclusivity
uh who decides that everything can be
exclusive everything can be exclusive it
doesn't matter if there's four or four
million because there could always be
more
um so we got the pockets stay deep very
very nice absolutely beautiful with that
Sparkle with the pot with the star in
the back pockets stay deep and we've got
the grow or die hoodies it is winter is
creeping up it's fall do you want to be
freezing in
or do you not we've got the beautiful
grow or die hoodies at chrisdelia.com so
go on over get that improved we also got
life rips decals for your car
uh and without further Ado let's make it
happen the next new Incredible exclusive
episode of congratulations
[Music]
brings up a good uh kind of uh point
there though doesn't it yeah it does oh
me nice
what is exclusivity you know really
really it's in the eye of the beholder
uh when I was when I was younger
somebody in my class thought it was the
eye of the beeholder and a guy was just
holding a b uh it's an idiot I got grown
up he's probably dead now
um so it's all good dude you live and
learn gird eye that's what we say yeah
you know uh but that's what's going on I
was in dude let me just actually start
off oh
okay so I was in a Little Rock Hey
Little Rock is a fantastic time in
Little Rock it's too hot
the thing about Little Rock is I I say
this now that I can then I've been there
and I should have said this on stage
while I was there because I did some
stuff on it and I'm gonna post it to my
YouTube uh but Little Rock Arkansas is
you know some people listen to this
overseas and first of all it's Little
Rock Arkansas is you want to know what
Little Rock Arkansas is okay here it is
it's the place that 48 Hours the first
that's where it's filmed the most is for
is either there or Memphis okay
um like you turn on the first 48 and
it's like Little Rock Arkansas you're
like of course they don't have to say it
anymore just say when it's not Little
Rock Arkansas
oh yeah and this also is in Little Rock
Arkansas
anyway we're trying to find out who did
it in 48 hours
um
so Little Rock Arkansas is
the
whitest and blackest place there is
the mix of super white and super black
in every sense
it's unbelievable dude
you've got like
oh first of all all sorts
uh like the the white
country good old boys that are you got
the ones with
like very very hey how's it going and
then the ones that are just like
and you're like oh you just spit
on a bird on the ground and they're like
I don't I don't look
what are you here for and then you got
we walked through a it's not just black
people we walked through Calvin and I
walked through
it was just me and him I took it was
just just dad and son Calvin at Little
Rock Arkansas Kristen and Williams
stayed at a wedding
uh in Vermont or something or no uh
Virginia I would say Vermont I'm not
coming to Vermont by the way I'm coming
to Virginia I may I may do Vermont at
some point but Virginia is where I'm
going I always Vermont and people hit me
up like where's the Vermont date and I
just say instead of Virginia because
they're both bees and I'm an idiot
um but
we went to
this place that was like the riverfront
or something
and
there was a full-on
not just concert all black people
and the most
soul
first I've ever been a part of Calvin's
ever been a part of but I've ever been a
part of dude I walked I was with Calvin
walking through Little Rock Arkansas and
the music kept getting louder and I
don't remember what song it was but it
was some [__] like I'm going down on I'm
going down
you know the [__] song or whatever
um and some lady you know some some
bigger black lady was just singing and
just killing it and I'm like we're
getting pretty close we're gonna have to
see what this is all black people dude
and black people just have a good time
you know what I'm talking about
it's just such a good time
and I'm like holding Calvin and I'm like
I kind of want to have one of these Good
Times
now I don't like but look I'm not black
and can I do it and also I don't want to
I hate concerts Hannah
but I don't want to impose that on
Calvin so what if he likes it so
I walk up and then I realize that
literally everybody is black and I'm
talking about there's
300 black people just at the riverfront
just listening to this lady sing pretty
damn well full-on band and they're all
just grooving to it you know
and I walk up and I'm like I guess I
gotta go in because if I don't I seem
racist right because if I'm like nah not
for me I'm like why not and I don't want
Calvin to think like that I want Calvin
to be exposed to everything so I just
[__] walk hey I just walk right up
I just walked right through and we
listened to some soul [__] dude Calvin
and I
and uh we were grooving a little bit and
we walked right through it was too hot
and then we got
there and I realized that you know what
I'm exposing Calvin to all sorts of
cultures and that's great and then
Calvin goes like this it's too loud
and so we left so
in a way he said black people are too
loud so that's racist um but I have a
resistance so
um
we went to a wedding
uh shout out to Mariel and Dom who got
married in uh
where were we even New York upstate
I never yeah I've been to Upstate New
York for shows and we were staying in
like a place it was a I guess it was a
hotel but there were more cabins and we
didn't have a TV and it was [__] the
first thing Calvin said when he woke up
he was like
why does this room have no TV we went to
bed when we got there we went to bed and
he when we woke up he said why does this
room not having TV I'm like buddy
some questions your father just can't
answer and um
and uh it's just it was so hot and [__]
and they got married it was beautiful
the wedding was beautiful we had a great
time and then we went on a trip to a
place
Fremont what the hell was it called Kirk
mend Kirkland I don't know some place
Upstate New York Fremont or Kirkland or
some [__] like that
and uh
we stayed in a house that was absolutely
haunted right now I don't believe in
that [__] I don't believe in that [__] I
don't believe houses are haunted I don't
believe any place is haunted because
ghosts don't exist know why where are
they because there was somebody in our
party because we stayed with like it was
like eight to ten people at the house
like all Kristen's friends from when she
was like in college and all the kids
that they they had and Calvin and
William and we were all there we were
having a good time dude
we got this Airbnb that if you looked at
it you'd be like okay haunted right
because when was it built absolutely not
in a century you know what I'm talking
about and I don't mean two thousands I
mean 90 like this [__] could have been
made before
like the Ryman Theater which I'll get to
because I played that in Nashville but
uh somebody looked up the history in the
house I'm like I'm not even looking
because it's gonna say something about
being haunted lo and behold the dead but
um
apparently the house was like a safe
haven for certain people in the war that
would like get shot or their legs would
get sewn off and then they would like
come and like seek Refugee at this house
so you know so one of the people in the
party was like oh this place is haunted
we're gonna wake up and there's gonna be
ghosts with like one leg and [__]
nobody ever sees ghosts that like just
died you know everyone's always like go
this is like some [__] somebody with
a bonnet and like a cane
with a with a monocle that's like
this is my house and you're in it it's
never some dude that's just like hey man
you're you're [__] up my algorithm
dude
those guys die
hey man
you're really [__] up my Hulu uh
wreck uh suggestions man
I can't even hit the remote because I'm
see-through
um
because that's the kind of ghost I would
be by the way who did I say what was I
saying this to I wouldn't be the ghost
if I was gonna haunt [__] who'd
I just I said this did I say this on my
tour report I don't know man we're
double dipping though if I'm haunted bro
I'm gonna be the most cool and ass Coast
I'm gonna be chilling but I'm gonna be
pissed off because people are gonna be
messing up my house
but I'm not gonna be like get out I'm
just gonna be like you better be a good
roommate but anyway
um
you better keep the fridge stock even
though I don't eat anymore cause I'm an
apparition
and
what the [__] is going on there's no
mayonnaise even though I can't eat it
there's no food in the afterlife and we
don't get to bus nuts
what the [__] I don't get the bus not to
reach ramp
dude busting nuts and eating shrimp like
I'm a [__] uh
Three Six Mafia member we eat so many
shrimps I get iodine poisoning That's
when hip-hop fell off so um
was that even them I don't even know but
they did do that oh they were [__] so
many so many tangents so we got to the
uh Place uh and it was a haunted house
it was a beautiful house big farmland
and [__] and um
I don't [__] with Airbnb I tell you you
know since my Seattle trip when I went
to go my cousin got married I don't [__]
with with Airbnb and I will tell you why
spiders okay there's never Hotel never
spiders in hotels always spiders and
airbnbs wasn't a spider this time thank
God was an absolute [__] snake in the
pool
[Music]
hey Four Seasons where you at dude hey
[__] Aloft or whatever that place is
where you at
straight up
a [__] snake in the pool
like it's a Sam Jackson sequel
[__]
get this goddamn snake out this it was a
little one and it was dead but still
dude
watch where you step dude we had like
six kids under five
so there's a snake in the pool yay uh
pool was fine it wasn't filled up all
the way still okay because it went deep
thank God but dude let me tell you
something about airbnb's man the people
who run airbnbs they don't give a [__]
they don't give a rat [__]
they go like this
it'll be fine that's what people who
have airbnbs they say that they go like
this ah the pillowcases ah [__] we need
this
we'll rent it out this weekend it's fine
it'll be fine they won't want to switch
the pillows and then what happens uh
right a raccoon comes in shits on the
pillow and then you need it but you
can't because they didn't stalk him and
you get texted I don't want to have to
text any I want the guy to be downstairs
somewhere you know
I want there to be a [__] if there
was a concierge in airbnbs great a
concierge a Bellman and if now I know
it's a lot cheaper and a better you know
to do Airbnb sometimes but you get what
you pay for man
got there needed the laundry laundry
machine didn't work yes
[Music]
when did I find that out beforehand no I
found it out afterwards when when I put
the clothes in there when right then
right when you put the clothes in there
no when I put the tide pod on it oh is
that when you find it out no when you
close the door on the tide button you
hit start and it kind of went but didn't
and then oh okay so you took the clothes
directly out no no no because it was
locked and I put it in the tide pod kind
of released into the clothes and so now
not only do my clothes smell like Bo but
they also smell like tide pod yes dude
so what the [__] did I did now I have to
reserve a whole new suitcase a whole
suitcase just for laundry because I
don't want my clean clothes smelling
like Bo into iPod ah yes dude
and I text the guy can you get a guy
come to come out and he says no because
it's Labor Day oh dude airbnb's for the
[__] and you had a snake in the pool
okay fine now here's the deal dude
that's too much so I say knock some
price off he knocked jujundo off is that
okay I'd rather not deal with it okay so
he knocked two hundo off and then guess
what dude he knocked your C notes off
and then guess what dude okay he knocked
two c notes he knocked two hundos off he
knocked two [__] right he knocked him
off he knocked off two bills and then
guess what dude then guess what
we had three days left
we had I swear to God one of the guys
staying there was one he wore a button
up the last day and I was like why are
you wearing a button-up shirt and he was
like that's the only thing that doesn't
smell like Bo okay
then guess what though what happened two
days before we all left well guess what
let's see what happened oh the [__]
air conditioner
[Music]
broke
[Applause]
I like to work out so now I'm Bo City
and it's so hot and dude check this out
the [__]
houses it's so hot we're standing on the
top floor and was it was there but no
about heat oh foreign
but we gotta worry about the [__]
baby right he's four five months old and
oh hell it's 150 degrees up there on
that third level oh [__] the baby's
gonna die all for [__] sake he didn't
right but I was worried and I'm smelling
and I'm sweaty dude
200 [__] it pay us to stay I don't even
want to be there anymore but the people
were very pleasant the people were nice
like the people that we stayed with it
was very nice Kristen's friends really
got to know them set up late nights with
them played [__] code names played
Catan dude I played Katan me I played
Katan dude I [__] won too see you
know what man
the boy doesn't play games but when he
does you give him two three games he'll
win the third one and he did dude did
you know it was funny too one of the
dudes he won the first game and my my uh
Kristen was unpacking and she went in my
my backpack and she felt like I get all
sorts of crazy [__] from
uh fans like just sometimes I get cool
[__] like they paint me pictures of like
this
and then sometimes I get like crazy [__]
like some guy goes like here's a shark
tooth and I'm like oh thanks
so
Kristin's going through my bag unpacking
everything she goes hey what the hell is
this and I'll look at it and she's like
and it's a big ass shark tooth like this
big with a necklace on it
and I'm like I have no [__] idea a
fan must have given it to me and I
didn't want to throw it away because I
didn't want to be rude
like I'm like I'm like I'm a
you know what I mean like I'm Stifler or
something like I'd wear it I mean dude
it was like a big it must have been fake
unless they got it from megalodon or
whatever maybe it's worth something I
have no idea so whoever won the game was
I gave them I said you are now the owner
of this shark tooth that's a joke one of
the other guys there didn't know that I
gave him
oh dude and he texted me on the side bro
he's actually on the side bro that's
crazy that dude bro
brought out his shark tooth necklace mid
trip
so the guy had
tooth necklace like you know [__]
these guys probably like me I could get
I could get away with just now and dude
I [__] didn't text him back because I
so badly wanted to just sit in that for
a bit man and I did
and then later I told him and and [__]
we had a laugh but then I won so I got
the shark tooth back so basically I'm Mr
shark tooth now I got that shark tooth
back
um
deep it's bluest my head is like a
shark's fin and it popped a good turn
um I eat some shrimps I got Ada
poisoning yeah hip-hop took a turn
deepest blue it's my head it's like a
shark fin and Hip Hop took a turn okay
so it's all good
so um
anyway uh we stayed there in that
haunted place and there's always one
person or or more than one person that
think that the the place is haunted like
someone takes a picture you know like we
had a Polaroid for somebody dude
Kristen's great she'll just be like
brought a Polaroid camera and you're
like what
on a trip isn't it clunky to bring we
had room and you're like okay and you
start taking Polaroids and of course
some of them had like weird flashes in
it and the person who thought that it
she was like see it's haunted
and you're like that's the flash from in
the mirror
there's no such thing as ghosts dude you
know like I'm not saying there's no no
afterlife there might be almost but
there's like to think of like ghosts
roaming around
like all those shows my buddy has won
the Ghost Hunters Ghost Adventures or
whatever the [__] it's like
yo I love the dude love him love him I
love him honestly
fake all good where are they where are
they dude
it's always the people that are like you
don't believe because they're like dude
the one time and you're like nah dude
come come correct man
if you saw a ghost you know how much
you'd want to not talk about it that's
where I'm at bro
so anyway we stayed there
and then uh Kristen was like why don't
you take Calvin to work when you go to
Little Rock and I'll keep William and go
to the wedding and I was like ah that
makes me like nervous to just be alone
with him while I'm working right because
like I I know I only I'm away for like
an hour when I'm on stage but what if
something happens and I sucked it up and
I'm like I want to do it dude I'm so
happy I did it man you could watch the
tour report
that we're gonna put up or maybe it's up
at this point I don't know yet but man
that was so awesome and the whole time I
was like I hope he's old enough to
remember this you know he's three and a
half and like uh like we had so much fun
just Palling around dude you forget you
forget that uh
like you're hanging and then all of a
sudden
ju like somebody mentioned like wow your
boy's being so good and I was like there
we go dude that's it right there you
just [__] us right you just [__] us
God he's so good and then what and then
what the iPad you know runs out of
batteries and then we're in nam all of a
sudden we're the [__] dude looking
for the grenade went off and he's
looking for his leg and Saving Private
Ryan and we're like great dude he can't
play [__] two three four whatever the
hell the game is called on iPad he can't
watch wacky inflatable Tube Man a lot of
YouTube videos that we download because
we have YouTube premium we can't watch
those anymore we can't watch the [__]
so now he's just
you know what I mean it's like that
movie Dunkirk
because the iPad ran out of batteries
and he's just like it died it died
dude my son's this [__] and I'll tell
you why he goes like this we were he was
coloring on the plane and
we're at the point now we're we're potty
training them and I talk about this on
stage I'm not gonna do too much of the
joke but like we're potty training them
and
um
foreign
it's like he needs to wear a diaper
still sometimes but we because he has
accidents right and sometimes he has
accidents when he sleeps and wets the
bed so Kristen's like dude just put the
[__]
put the [__] uh diaper on when he
sleeps and I'm like you know headstrong
I'm like nah we gotta ride it out you
know it'll piss on everything I don't
give a [__] uh he's on the plane and I
got him so I don't have him wearing a
diaper dude he's coloring and he goes
like this I'm paying dad and I'm like oh
no on the plane seat and I go wait did
you pee it or rep and he says yes I'm
peeing I like to
so enjoy the seat whoever sits there
next we tried to wipe it up but um
it's all good
I don't really you know it's like
[Applause]
and then we went to Nashville dude I
played we played the Ryman
the Ryman uh Raymond the Ryman and
um it is I man I played a lot of venues
I think it's the number one venue there
is it's an old it's like it got church
pews pews in it Church pubes it's got
church pews in it it was made in
1860 something or 1892. you know what I
mean I brought Lola I brought
um uh openers Lulu Denny and Andrew uh
sorry and Adam W and uh
and uh Andrew man I'm [__] up left
and right Church pubes Ryman and I
called him Andrew
um Adam W Lulu and uh Denny and we did a
show there and it was crazy that we did
a show and the place was built when my
openers couldn't even get inside but uh
so did a show there was awesome the
Ryman is absolutely phenomenal dude it's
one of the venues that I would see like
just go to any show just to see it
and uh
Nashville is cool man it's really really
a cool place
uh I've come around on it because I
don't like places that everyone always
talks about like Austin and [__] but you
know you go to Austin you have a good
time Nashville has a cool it's too much
music just too much music stop with the
music you don't need to have music in
every place I mean I've said this before
probably I said it on stage but I'm like
dude you don't have to have music in
just like they they because I was like
hey I went down to the the
concierge at the
um
hotel and I was like Hey where's the
best coffee shop that's not Starbucks
because that's a [__] sucks because
because of how much Starbucks sucks and
he was like oh there's a place called
just love coffee or some [__] I don't
know this way that way this way that way
go in there I go in there of course dude
live music and I'm like [__] God damn it
I just want four shots over ice and some
you know woman is on stage singing to 12
people just
[Applause]
and I'm like it's too loud we can't talk
we gotta be quiet God forbid we say
something too loud and [__] her Rhythm
up I'm a performer I don't want to [__]
it up but like you know
and then she finishes the song and then
three people clap and I'm like it's not
enough I gotta help
and it's like dude you don't need to
have I feel like this place is in
Nashville they're like oh we have to
you know we have to we're in Nashville
so
I know it's a Banana Republic but
where's the stage gonna be
you're looking at a sweater vest
zombie zombie zombie
just putting on pants cargo pants in the
[__] fitting room
baby this is the day
today no I don't think I like these
stand in the place where you are owl
face laughing about erect and wonder why
then in that place where you are
so bad
um
but the but so it's too much music
everywhere
let's talk about something dude
the fashion in Nashville
is atrocious
hey
look I'm not a cowboy hat guy if you're
gonna wear a cowboy hat wear it with a
cowboy outfit
okay at least wear it with Wrangler
jeans
okay at least wear it with a top with
one of those with two pockets here and
they have the the the you know what I
mean the triangle thing where you lift
up and put the thing in at least wear it
with that
dude [__] are out here in
Nashville wearing cowboy hats with like
an Adidas jumpsuit
or or even worse
a double-breasted suit
don't wear a cowboy hat
and Air Force Ones [__]
and the women dude if you're gonna wear
a cowboy hat
it better be tan
if you're gonna wear a cowboy hat better
be black with tassels
dude these [__] idiots will wear like
a like a scaly White
pink with the [__]
and like
and like what do you call it with the
the not the
Fringe on the dress or some [__] and
you're like Yo dude
Dolly Parton me take that off
well producers go like this
but take that off your head dead
of your head
unbelievable dude the fashion in
Nashville is some of the worst I've ever
seen straight up
it's crazy dude you know what it's like
one of those things where they like the
the things slide like the you'll have a
person and you have one in thirds and it
slides both ways and you gotta hit the
thing like a like a what do you call the
the slot machines and you gotta line up
the person and you just get get what you
get that's what a guy looks like in
Nashville just like with like cowboy
boots [__] cargo shorts and then his
top is like swimmies
and that's a guy in Nashville
that like will tell you something
and you're like oh
huh
it's incredible so
shape up huh Nashville would don't want
to come to the fashion
um my buddy took me to the Soho house to
get a coffee
I was like I wanna get a coffee you
won't come pick me up you know because I
had to [__]
I I had him come out by and I was like
where we want to get a coffee and he was
like let's go to sofas they have really
good iced coffee so I was like okay
[__] so we went to the Soho House
that's that place where like you can pay
like two thousand dollars a year to like
become a member or some [__] I don't
know I don't have it but
uh and then you go which I like would
have never thought would have worked but
like we went and it was like
how does that work how does [__] Soho
House work dude
how does it work it's a restaurant and
then it has like a movie theater in it
that you can like schedule watching
stuff in and then like
a bar
and you there's like a membership uh
hey you're just a place
like go [__] yourself
like the [__] sucking energy at SoHo
houses
it's unreal and they got one like
downtown and in Beverly Hills in
Nashville and like one in Toronto and
then London and you could like pay
thousands of dollars a year to go into a
play
dude it's so cocksuck
it's ridiculous dude what do you do you
go in you get you sit down and get some
olives and a tart ah I'm in the place
and the one in Nashville had like a pool
and it's like
in a gym and I'm like this is a [__]
hotel without the rooms dude like I'm
like you just
and I said this is a hotel without the
rooms you just pay yearly and he's like
yeah and he's like but it actually does
have rooms and I'm like oh wait so it's
just a hotel
this one in Nashville just a hotel and
there's suckering [__] to pay a
membership
there's people out there in pools nobody
was attractive except dudes the dudes
were fit as [__]
one chick was kind of attractive but
whatever
you're just a place you know that'd be
like if somebody like put made a
membership for Marie Calendars and [__]
all they'd have to do is like add like a
grassy knoll on the outside and be like
oh yeah you gotta pay
you gotta pay dude look at Mike Lindell
my pillow [__] just
CR crushed under pressure you know
I love this I love you know I love the
my pillow and I don't they're not paying
me to say this dude the my pillows are
[__] I have five of them dude I I love
my pillow so much I sleep on them and
hold them I hold them like they're
[__] dogs and I go to sleep and I
can't without holding on my pillow I
hold my pillow so much in bed that my
wife's like why is there always a my
pillow between us and I'm like you want
me to get good sleep or not
foreign
I said let's have sex and she said I
don't know if I really feel like like
and I go like this I brought to my
pillow out I put it in between us she
started laughing just a little marriage
humor you know
dude look at Mike Lindell [__]
concave under a little bit of pressure
okay and I'm not asking about is this
one there was uh what's the word
deposition with the the January 6th what
the [__] did the my pillow guy have to
do with this by the way did he put out
information about it
I don't even know how'd they lumped a my
pillow guy in on this
January 6th [__]
yeah but like in what way is he part of
it
he always is always holding the pillow
who's trying who's [__] trusting him
who's believing a [__] he says isn't
this guy a comedy isn't he a character
he's a comedy character you can't put
him in jail for being like yeah it's an
Insurrection and we gotta go take back
the government he's on the [__]
pillow all the time I see these guys on
the pillow he's got a pill he's sitting
on a pill I swear to God in his
deposition he brought a pillow
the lumpy pillow called look at this
dude you do not this is like when he you
call his pillow lumpy that's like in
Biff and Back to the Future once you
call him chicken
dude look he takes off he goes to put
here he takes off his glasses when
somebody calls him a lumpy because of
pillow lumpy just how you know how
gangsters is because he takes off the
glasses it's not just the fact that he
takes off the glasses is because
three seconds before them
he put them on dude so you knew he was
getting ready to like either read
something or chill with his glasses on
he put them on somebody called a pillow
lumpy he goes like this oh oh oh [__]
let's rewind some time
okay and I'm not asking about here we go
put some glasses on lumpy and chocolate
lumpy pillows that's not what they call
him oh dude honorary no no they're not
them
so good
okay and I'm not asking about the lumpy
pillow calls no they're not lumpy
pillows that's not what they call on
okay that when you say lumpy pillows now
you're an [__] you got oh dude and
it's not enough to just call him an
[__] to drill the point home he's
amazing watch it now you're an [__]
you got that confirming he understands
is the absolute get this dude honestly
is the Tony Soprano of betting and I I
I'm like this is unreal okay they're not
lumpy pillows all right and and and and
you know you call it an Olympic pillow
and that's what makes you an [__]
until you got that
you're an [__] drilled at home what
you are like no he's an [__] nice
in contempt an [__] that's what you
are lumpy pillows kiss my ass
set
in contempt
put that in your book
oh dude put that in your book such a
white guy thing to say and why don't you
put that in your book huh Jim any
Christmas
foreign
they answer anything any problem
customer that wants to reach Mike
Lindell those are the ones dude like
he's Ricky Henderson it's so dope to do
yourself in third person when you sell
pillows
I want to talk to Mike Lindell I want to
talk to Mike Lindell they send them to
here and they go
or they call about um maybe they didn't
get their pillow on time because of uh
um the FedEx or whatever well we'll
cover them even though it could be that
somebody else's fault nobody calls
because of a lumpy pillow
but good good one though you're done
smash dumb dude guy says you're done
yeah I'm done now I like that I like
that he goes yeah I'm done
I liked that
now here's why you can't trust them
what I'm saying obviously you don't have
it yeah it wasn't done dude
wasn't done love it I'm done I'm done
and another thing dude the Tony Soprano
of betting yeah I'm done
here we go what I'm saying obviously you
don't have my pillow too product
placement dude uh you probably wouldn't
be in such a bad mood if you got a good
night's sleep
if you don't do you
what I'm saying is Mr Lindell [__]
oh dude just yo pressure
hey dude don't call my pillows lumpy man
I swear to God this guy's a rapper go
ahead no I'm pissed yep I understand
yeah go when you're saying what oh dude
I don't even know what the [__] how did
it like what's with the lumpy pillows
like why how did that even come up you
know this is just a clip but wow Michael
and Dell just [__] absolutely
crushing Under Pressure but also
applying pressure we love it I love
[__] my pillows dude and I love Mike
Lindell so there we go hey guys I want
to take a break I want to talk to you
about something that's a new thing we're
doing here in this podcast uh holler dot
baby that's the website holler dot baby
and uh it's a new thing kind of that
we're trying to do where you can buy
shout outs or like quote unquote mini
ads for me on this podcast all you got
to do is go to my page holler dot baby
slash crystallia and write what you want
me to say and then I say it uh it's as
simple as that uh so you know go check
it out it's cool it's a website uh some
other podcasts are doing it already but
um we're jumping on board and uh you
could do anything you want you go ahead
go have me say Happy Birthday to someone
for you or plug your pizza shop or
whatever if you work in a Radio Shack
that you really love and you want to
shout out then we'll do that too
actually I specifically would like to do
one to a Radio Shack but um we'll put
all the info up on the screen and in the
description below hollow.baby slash
crystallia and if you get it now in the
next few days then we'll put it up on
the following weeks episode so that's
how it'll be but yes a hollow dot baby
slash crystallia so go peruse man we're
still figuring out the pricing and all
that but it'll be up on the page so go
to holler.baby slash crystallia and see
what's up
oh dude this one was funny so many
people sent me this this one was funny
but my God
is it it's it's a level of funny
that's pretty damn funny the last second
the last second thing
the last second dude it is unreal it was
like when [__] Dogecoin exploded
[Music]
I mean dude
is that a guy a real voice like the dog
just
dog handled him you know what I mean
like the dog just [__] straight up
took him out to let hey guy let go see
that's the thing you shouldn't wrap that
thing around like it's a [__] turbo
Graphics a handheld turbo graphic 16
that you're gonna draw because of the
excitement you need to hold the leash
like like like this only like this you
don't go and then hook around it then
the dog takes you places right the dog
walks you hey dog you don't walk me I
walk you right you're in front of me but
I'm holding it like this not like a
handheld turbo graphic 16 that you could
drop because of the excitement okay
foreign
money and they it came with a little
[__] like strap thing I'll never
forget this dude and it was like this is
the excitement strap you need to uh you
need to strap on and have it on when
you're playing it in case the game gets
too exciting and you drop it and I did
it and then I told my friend about it
and he was like well I got this drop and
I was like in case the game gets too
exciting
but anyway
you know I like to play by the rules so
uh uh the guy falls because of it
because the dog walks him and then the
and then and then the lady just
doesn't give a [__] you know their
marriage is so over it's been over for
30 years and she's just like all right
this is the best
[Music]
sort of so wind out of knocked his
window
here's the last second coming up
private okay
you know what you're up to up there
feeling bad huh you're up to some
feeling bad man ow oh dude gonna be so
much in pain the next day you know
honestly you not only could have but
should have died right there being that
old and having that dog just [__]
drag you out
honestly I think that that wife when she
walked out she just kept going and left
him
we gotta play this again
[__] him she goes that's me
here we go dog shoots out doors open
boom knocked over there
doesn't give a [__] he threw the chair
which is great I've done that before
when I was mad uh
I mean why is he doing it like he's
making fun of her get the dog you know
how you like to get it [__] Adam
Sandler
who gets a dog
don't make a seat she's sad what dude if
you know what I would have miraculously
gotten better and left
left the marriage
when you're in pain and someone tells
you don't make a scene dude that's when
I [__] myself and make them clean it up
this is part of it
watch
I'm gonna go back upstairs Debbie and
just be in private okay the level of how
much he was trying to control his voice
into a normal tone and Cadence
it makes my it makes my all the parts of
humor in my body swell
my humor glands swell
just to the point where they're just
getting rubbed to bust a nut dude I love
it so much dude I love it so much that
you know what like controlling his
diaphragm so much and the the the the
the frenulum tip on my humor gland is
getting touched so nicely when he does
that that I'm just about to just squirt
to Infinity
when he does see
yeah
you know what Debbie I'm gonna go up and
just just be in private when you know he
just wants to piss [__] and scream in
divorce and that is so amazing dude
I gotta watch it one more time dude for
my for my humor glands
for my for my frenulum tip
dude
wait come on
[Music]
she says don't make a scene what a
[__]
the dog's gone and so she gotta go back
upstairs dude and just be in private
okay
oh dude the level of
funniness and then
[Music]
oh
that flight left late but so happy it
did
God so good
bro let's just I know this is kind of
racist to talk about this but
we're gonna
Indian rap battles hey
listen man
wraps just one of those genres that's
just it's not
it's not going to be Indian okay let's
just all the other cultures and
languages cool but hey
hey hey once you hear this
subscribers
hey you know what go back to your hello
whatever I know it sounds racist but
dude
on [__] nothing Rhymes just
dude here's how you know it's so bad
they start saying English words in it
because they're just like you know [__]
[__] this though right
come on dude here we go
Indian rap battles dude
practices Mickey Mouse it said Mickey
Mouse dude how about in a here's how you
know it's bad
what [__] rap battle have you ever
seen where people just break out into
Applause in the middle of it
dude imagine you had like freeway and
Beanie Siegel going at it and then and
then that somebody did something Memphis
Bleak was just like dude and everyone
else was like oh [__] man
dude
the [__] month on a bunch oh dude
forget it he did
dude unbelievable dude
this is just unreal dude
we gotta play
dude he said Mickey Mouse and then the
other guy said we already like Mickey
Mouse
and then the guy's like just joking
this honestly they're dressed like
people in Nashville
you represent Mickey Mouse dude and that
was the that was the line dude
hey Indians
you know
so good
uh
ah come on my internet sucks yes dude
but you're with me but you're with me
oh this is great
um what is the language of origin
uh Ethiopian to Amharic come on
[Music]
a king it's used as a title of the
Sovereign of Ethiopia Amigos nigas I
mean come on dude
ruled Ethiopia until the coup of 1970.
come on dude this white kid sweating
so canceled dude we're gonna demonetized
because of this
is
Andrew would you say the word loudly for
the judges
thank you now go to prison
[__]
oh dude and that's when the black
community accepted him
he was so surprised at the end he got
that wow
I mean hey pick different words for it
you know
next word
flag it
next word flag it from the origin of
what in West Hollywood the king of West
Hollywood can you use it was it what's
the definition of the king of West
Hollywood flag it
um
ah man
my son I just hear my son outside saying
I'm going poop so he's using the toilet
awesome speaking of toilets Delta flight
returns after passengers diarrhea all
the way through playing hey dude you
know it must have been David Sullivan
for real
dude
David Sullivan will eat everything on
the planet but not but get it without
cheese and he'll be like man I don't
know why my stomach hurts
I don't know why my stomach hurts I
didn't eat the cheese and you're like
yeah dude you ate everything else you
ate jalapenos and ice cream
um
passengers reboard flight to Spain
after eight hour delay while social
media posts described flight crew
mopping up mess
wow dude passengers reboard flight to
Spain that's so great to happen in Spain
you know the most romantic City and they
just [__] [__] all over the aisle of
a Delta of of of a 747.
footage their footage of it footage is
everywhere you know God footage is
everywhere footage has emerged of the
onboard medical emergency that's so
great that
the one suffering diarrhea
uh
allowed to reboard after an eight-hour
delay making wow he was allowed to
reboard Jesus Christ I would give him a
[__] butt plug
give him a seat with a dildo on it
they tried to do their best to mop up
the mess with paper towels
ah
and doing the best paper towels and
scented disinfectant but but that only
had the effect of making the plane quote
smell of vanilla [__] one passenger said
that's like that old uh Robert Robert
schimel joke another describe Kevin crew
give it where he's like you ever [__]
and then you you use Lysol and it smells
like you [__] in the forest uh another
described cabin crew placing a
an exorbent paper run runner over the
aisle dude imagine having a deep plane
because some guy ate a goddamn chalupa
dude I would be so pissed off
so they had to go back down
and on uh on the ground
because they called it an onboard
medical issue
I'll tell you what
if I knew we were going down
if I knew we were going down because of
a guy taking a [__] on the by the way
how do you not know it's coming get to
the toilet quicker and also don't uh
have it leak out you know hold your pain
or tuck them in you know tuck your
[__] pants and your socks or or what
are you wearing shorts on plane I guess
don't wear shorts on plane but then
again you're in Spain and probably
everyone wearing shorts on Spain on the
plane because it's [__] you know it's
like it's super cool like romantic town
you just kind of want your balls flown
but
I if I was on a plane and then did the
people [__] all over the aisle guess
what in case your boy's doing right then
[__] and pissing where the hell he
wants to if we're going we're going
we're Landing anyway I don't give a [__]
dude
look at this they wrote this article
this place wrote this article the
guardian and then they wrote
I hope you appreciate this article
before we move on I was hoping you
consider taking a step of supporting the
guardian's journalism you know go suck
my are you kidding me
look at this from Elon Musk to Rupert
Murdoch a small number of billionaire
owners have a powerful hold on so much
of the information that reaches the
public about what's happening in the
world dude they just did an article
about how someone [__] on the plane
put that after the other political
articles you know
I love how this strike yo let me ask a
question this actors and writer strike
what's going on because they're still
making movies they get all exemptions
and [__] there's so many different
levels of corruption in this [__]
it's such [__] Malarkey and horseshit
Drew Barrymore is still doing her talk
show
the only thing
that makes the Drew Barrymore worse than
the Drew Barrymore show
is no writers
the show's so bad
and she's just like
dude the [__]
these actors don't give a [__] about
anything but themselves Drew Barrymore
slammed by Hollywood for bringing talk
show back amid strikes
um
Drew Barrymore is being criticized by
fellow actors and writers on social
media for a decision to bring back to
Drew Bremer's show is set to return
April 18th and then it's that's in the
middle of the [__] strike Barrymore
is not violating sag afro rules but yeah
no [__] because there's [__]
exemptions and also uh
so many different levels of corruption
um uh
Guild contract for talk shows game shows
variety shows and soap operas was
renewed and ratified in 2022. her show
does employ wga writers
this means that so it has to go without
writers without wga writers or or no
writers dude I'd love to see if she
Wings it first in line to watch it I
can't watch that I can't wait to watch
that train wreck but people are pissed
off like uh you know uh what's his name
from West Wing and then the other guy
from the other show
I say it that way because who [__]
cares who's pissed off you know uh
this person Jennifer gross who spells
Jennifer with the G so we can trust her
says Drew Barrymore has always been
someone who would recognized her
privilege and aimed to evolve so I hope
she will reconsider this hasty decision
intended to pay her crew because it
weakens both unions to openly endorse
scabbing
she could personally fund their salaries
for eternity I mean you know like this
is where you lose me no she can't
for eternity don't ever say
eternity in any argument
Lonnie Love who I actually [__] love
I love Lonnie Love she said uh if you're
giving if you're giving Drew Barry more
heat you got to hit all the other shows
someone is writing still the focus
should be on getting the studios back to
the table so everyone get back to work
she's right London love is the [__]
um
oh Adam Conover that guy
who always has something to say about
everything dude
this is incredibly disappointing Drew
Barrymore shows it employs wga writers
who are currently on strike she's
choosing to go back on the air without
them and forcing her guests to cross a
picket line Drew this arms of writers
and all the union workers please
reconsider because like I [__] talks
about anything a [__] livable by Ben
Affleck and it'll be like you know we
need to talk about this leave situation
Bradley Whitford dude oh you dude these
[__] people just come out of the
woodwork Drew Barrymore I own this
choice we are in compliance with not
discussing or promoting film and
television that is instruct that is
struck of any kind I don't know and
Bradley Whitford oh you own it for sure
Drew Barrymore and we'll never forget it
I love it dude
so good everyone is sucks you know
except Lonnie love I love her
um
uh anyway dude
God this [__] Jimmy Fallon thing is
so crazy
the [__] non-article is so insane
dude
you read this thing that [__] kuck
ass Rolling Stone made I mean dude they
just make an article about anything they
[__] made an article about how Jimmy
Fallon is mean sometimes
I don't give a [__] this whole thing
about Ellen like the Ellen one was a
little bit more uh
you know eye-opening I guess if you say
but I don't give a [__] if your boss is
me who gives a [__] Jimmy Fallon's as
[__] and he went to he thinks we got in
touch with 50 employees uh we we rolling
stone are called a hundred uh employees
that used to work for The Tonight Show
or somebody worked for that show dude
you're gonna get something negative
you're gonna get something negative yeah
you know sometimes he's a good guy but
also sometimes when he was a bad mood
all bets were off and one time he was
drunk and it was it was we were walking
on eggshells and some guys said that
they got uncomfortable and they got so
uncomfortable that they they turned
their Tonight Show dream into their
Nightmare and they never wanted to work
in the on in entertainment television
again hey dude that guy's a [__]
stop coddling these [__] dude I
read that article on Jimmy Fallon it
ain't [__] dude and I know you'd be like
oh it's Crystal here he's toxic bro stop
throwing that word around these [__]
articles are lies dude you could talk to
you can it's so ridiculous what they did
to Jimmy Fallon man
it's so ridiculous and then people are
like oh wow a [__] another white guy
with his privilege dude
this Society it is no not Society the
media is so [__]
shitty to white men it's on and also
just men that it's just unreal
it's so shitty to men it's unreal the
media it's so crazy and everyone no one
will talk about it because oh you know
people are starting to talk about nobody
don't talk about because they don't want
to get in trouble bro I've been in
trouble already I don't give a [__]
it's so dumb dude and then people online
will just pretend go they don't [__]
even believe it but they're doing oh man
this sucks about Jimmy Fallon and then
you talk to them and they're like yeah
they got him man I hope they don't get
me it's such [__] horseshit dude
read the Jimmy Fallon article it's
nothing dude
it's nothing they tried to [__] act
like Seinfeld he was on set with
Seinfeld and Seinfeld uh and Jimmy
Fallon yelled at somebody uh on set that
Seinfeld was there and Seinfeld was like
no Jimmy apologized to him and they
tried to act like it was this tense
moment that made everyone awkward and
then Seinfeld put out a statement that
was like yo it wasn't like that I love
Jimmy Fallon and we talk sometimes this
is the [__] that the media does dude
I mean dude it's unbelievable and
obviously I have my gripes about it but
dude the [__] the piss piss poor
journalism that they do
just to [__] promote an agenda that
gets clicks I guess
oh what they want what they want Jimmy
Fallon to lose his job [__] out of here
this is why every single day I thank the
[__] people that show up and sit in
seats dude
because I'm so grateful for these
[__] to see through the
[__] man Jimmy Fallon go on tour see
who loves you because you're going
through a rough time where you think
everybody wants to [__] kill you
trust me dude
trust me
I see through the lies these people who
show up and [__] sit down to watch
you do comedy
are the [__] that get it
and every day I'm grateful for these
every day I see the fans come out and
make this about me now but I see the
fans come out dude and I see how
effusive they are and how much how how
down they are and now I'm [__] double
down for them I I everybody that comes
and sits in a seat for [__] a comedy
show
I don't have dude I don't have any deals
I don't have brand deals I don't have
everything is direct to Consumer
everything is from me direct to Consumer
maybe I have one or two deals I have no
idea I don't want to speak how to turn I
can't think right now but these guys are
out there [__] you know Bert
Chrysler's doing a deal with dude wipes
or whatever the [__] it is hey I wipe my
[__] so I don't come too early with my
wife all right I get it bro bro I don't
have any of that [__] my [__] is all
direct consumer and the people who sit
down they see through the [__] and I
love you [__] for that [__] I
love you [__] for that [__]
and the media can keep coming after
[__] Jimmy Fallon or whoever the [__]
it is
trying to play the Tupac thing but I
can't
it's broken
um
yeah dude I love it man I mean it's so
it's so shitty
uh uh that they do that to a man it's
like bosses are shitty sometimes you
know why because people are shitty
sometimes the exactly this is a [__]
privileged thing God is supposed to be a
comedy podcast
but they act like it's a privileged
thing dude it's just a person thing some
of this [__] some of this [__] not all
of it some of the [__] yeah it's a
privileged thing like Drew Barrymore
thinking about how she's gonna [__]
still do her show
why doesn't the media eat that [__] up
it's just some [__] janky post from
New York Post
or the blast media
hey this is what people said on Twitter
do a [__] thing on that
nah they don't give a [__] because it
ain't Jimmy Fallon
uh
uh it ain't a guy
all right that's it I'm hot whoa uh
appreciate you guys uh you guys are
great uh I'll be in Ottawa I'll be in
um
Pittsburgh I'll be in Cleveland I'll be
in Detroit I'll be in Orlando I'll be in
Fort Myers Richmond Virginia uh
Baltimore Philadelphia and Reading
Pennsylvania
go to chrissy.com and uh that's it for
the YouTube episode we will see you guys
on patreon if you want to see the rest
of it patreon.com Crystal yet for just
six bucks you get the rest of the
episode you get all the rest of all the
episodes you get all the extended uncut
episodes and you get like 35 episodes
that have already been aired because we
do one a month and we've been on this
patreon thing for a while so patreon.com
Chrisley and I appreciate every one of
you [__] I love you thank you
thank you
[Music]